bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live nous allons
vous faire vivre en direct la cérémonie
consacrée à l'entrée au panthéon de
joséphine baker star du music-hall de
l'entre-deux-guerres figure éminente de
la résistance et de la lutte antiraciste
l'artiste franco-américaine fait son
entrée aujourd'hui 30 novembre 2000 21
dans ce temple républicain cette date du
30 novembre n'est pas le fait du hasard
il s'agit du jour anniversaire de
l'acquisition par joséphine baker de la
nationalité française c'était en
1937 pour commenter cet événement j'ai
le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
christine clerc journaliste grand
reporter prix albert londres et écrivain
bonjour christine clerc merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je suis ravi de
vous avoir à mes côtés pour pour
commenter cet événement les fidèles
lecteurs du figaro vous connaissent vous
connaissent bien vous êtes ancienne
plume du figaro et puis on continue à
vous lire régulièrement dans les pages
débats et opinions et du journal et sur
figaro box vous est également l'auteur
de nombreux livres autour de la
politique et de l'histoire dont quatre
ouvrages je crois sur le général de
gaulle pour revenir à notre sujet
d'aujourd'hui à joséphine baker
aujourd'hui est la nation en un hommage
solennel à joséphine baker pour les plus
jeunes qui la découvrent mais aussi pour
tous ceux qui nous suivent et qui
suivent l'histoire avec intérêt qui
était cette femme hors du commun quel
portrait peut-on dresser rapidement de
cette femme extraordinaire d'abord c'est
une extraordinaire vitalité parce que
quand on voit son enfance dans une
misère il lui arrive de passer trois
jours sans manger pour aussi de se faire
engager dans un music hall et elle dort
pas mais même plus tard elle dans des
spectacles presles va souper elles
rentrent à 2 heures du matin à les lever
à 7 elle parcourt le monde sait c'est
ahurissant
et puis c'est une femme d'entousiasme
avec tout ce qu'elle a subi d'autres
seraient dans la plate jusqu'à la subit
c'est à dire la misère c'est à dire des
mariages successifs dès l'âge de 15 ans
des hommes des femmes d'abord et non
elle a l'air toujours souriante toujours
joyeuse elle ne porte pas le malheur du
monde elles portent l'entousiasme et
c'est ça qui est merveilleux un jour
comme aujourd'hui nous nous qui sommes
dans une période où on a tendance à se
plaindre de tout à dire qu'on n'aime pas
notre pays elle elle se plaint pas elle
dit qu'elle adore son pays son pays la
france qu'elle a choisi elle est née à
saint louis états unis elle a quitté les
états unis pour venir en france venir en
france dans les années 20 se produire au
terrier champs elysées dans une revue
[ __ ]
c'était la grande mode à l'époque tous
les artistes achetait des statuts [ __ ]
guillaume apollinaire et picasso s'était
disputé des statues dans quelques-unes
avait peut-être été volée au louvre
enfin voici un truc très très à la mode
et elle est venue en france se produire
on a à ce moment là on a même exigé
d'elle mettant en scène qu'elle se met
nue elle ne voulait pas aller dit je
vous retourne états unis mais le pensais
pas vraiment parce qu aux etats unis
elle ne pouvait pas en elles pouvaient
entrer dans un restaurant mais elle ne
pouvait pas commander un repas et quand
elle est arrivée en france elle a été
accueillie elle a été au restaurant
à l'époque où elle quitte les etats-unis
c'est la négation de la ségrégation
racisme légal et à la libre et news et
le traitement qui lui est réservé les
pannes et elle est même hervé y est elle
dit que c'est un pays merveilleux
qu'elle veut être française et puis
ensuite il ya la guerre la résidence sur
plus dire elle tombe amoureuse entre
guillemets du général de gaulle idées et
des résistants et elle veut être de
cette famille là ce sont ces son idéal c
sont enthousiasmés et ce je trouve ça
merveilleux de cet enthousiasme
communicative qu'on le reçoivent
aujourd'hui
et un enthousiasme qu'elle a mis jusqu'à
la fin de cette guerre d'un fou saison
il ya une vitalité incroyable parce que
quand elle entre dans la résistance en
fait elle a entamé une tournée à travers
toute l'afrique du nord rappelons que
des particules que l'algérie était
département français à l'époque mais
elle parcourait et l'art à ce moment là
avait été engagé par les américains et
puis c'est seulement un moment le
général billotte l'a remarqué et 10 mais
ça on va pas du tout on va lui demander
et elle a dit qu'elle ne voulait pas
être payés à leurs qualités payer pour
ces tournées par les soldats elle en
libye au liban au maroc elle revenait en
tunisie elle retraverser de l'altérer
enfin c'était un périple est
extraordinaire on se produisant quelque
fois plusieurs fois par jour ont des
soldats pour leur donner le moral et
c'est à ce moment là on va y venir
qu'elle va rencontrer le général alors
absolument mais un plan de revenir un
engagement dans la résistance beaucoup
de gens voient à quoi ressemble
joséphine baker évidemment derrière moi
même il y a un formidable visuel réa vie
réalisé par kevin et biterne pour cette
émission quand elle arrive en france en
1925 je crois son succès il est
incroyable elle triomphe à paris dans
les années 20 puis à l'étranger elle
incarne la musique colle elle devient
chanteuse comédienne et même une icône
de la mode c'était on peut le dire la
première star noire mondiale
comment s'explique ce succès de cette
femme noire ce succès jamais vu vous
percevez noir c'était une période
privilégiez une période où après la
guerre de 14-18 et avant l'autre guerre
il ya une sorte de défoulement collectif
il ya fait tous les soirs avec apparaît
dans les théâtres les théâtres sont
pleins on va souper on se couche très
tard il ya
pas trop de limites morales oui bon tout
le monde peut avoir des le corner taxes
élevées comme vous êtes alors le corps
nu à là c'est quand même une innovation
oui au point c'est une évasion plus les
bananes ça fait beaucoup mais à partir
de mal à accepter l anjou l on joue avec
des amis grimace avec des mimiques
des images d'elle même à quatre pattes
les fesses en l'air si je peux dire
qu'ils qui aujourd'hui finalement nous
paraissent très choquant ensuite surtout
si on est elle avait pleinement
conscience mais de les marier d'aboyer l
envi de nabors calais et puis quand elle
a vu que ça triomphait et du coup elle
est devenue l'instar d'un spectacle où
il y avait beaucoup de danseuses mais
qui tu es dans une attitude beaucoup
plus classique et sacrée un enthousiasme
extraordinaire et elle l'a ressenti elle
avait ressenti non pas avec amertume
comme d'autres auraient pu le ressentir
mermet avec joie d'être accepté par
d'être accepté par la france est
immédiatement elle a dit qu'elle voulait
qu'elle voulait être français est-ce que
c'était son rêve et justement pour pour
la pour la france et ce pour quoi on est
là aujourd'hui ce pourquoi elle entre au
panthéon aujourd'hui c'est que cette
cérémonie permet effectivement de
rappeler son engagement dans la
résistance qui demeure un peu un peu mal
connu un de cette existence knvb
essentielle ment placé sous les
projecteurs garder musicaux et
soulignons folies bergères et de ça et
finalement j'avoue que moi je l'ignorais
d'avoir tout ce périple à travers toute
l'afrique du nord mme tous les sens pour
les américains puis auprès de l'armée
française et puis auprès des la
résistance même si à un moment elle a
été hospitalisée elle a été très malade
ne sais pas si un mois l'a fait une
fausse couche qui s'est passé était
plusieurs mois à l'hôpital entend tout
ça entre casablanca et alger et mais à
partir de ce moment là elle est entrée
elle est entrée au service de la france
avec beaucoup d'amour et sans compter
son temps mais c'est extraordinaire
parce qu'il ne serait ce que ça elle et
elle les stars du music-hall elle va
devenir agent du contre-espionnage prête
à donner sa vie pour la france comment
elle entre dans la résistance comment on
devient résistante et les honneurs du
contre-espionnage d'abord comme un
divertissement pour les soldats c'est à
dire qu'elle ait donné des concerts des
fêtes est massif dit une récompense pour
les soldats les soldats américains
d'abord les soldats français ensuite et
et la
décide donc de ne pas se faire payer
alors qu'on lui proposait de la payer et
puis et ja dire allez prends goût parce
que elle les voit se réveiller à lui
alors comme unique un tel enthousiasme
qu'elle de comptes plus son temps elle
est là plusieurs séances par jour et de
nuit et puis là elle va rencontrer le
général de gaulle la rencontre des des
gens de la résistance de du gouvernement
français qui est installé à alger et à
ce moment là de bhola beaucoup de soucis
à d'abord son combat contre le général
giraud pour prendre le pouvoir de la
résistance et puis il reçoit des
mauvaises nouvelles de la famille et à
ses ânesses geneviève qui a été arrêté
et déporté oui et à sa propre soeur est
arrêté avec son beau frère il ya un
petit neveu qui est mort au combat donc
beaucoup de beaucoup de nouvelles très
sombre énormément de soucis
et néanmoins il va quand même à l'opéra
d'alger une soirée où se produit
joséphine baker et à l'entracte qui
demandait ce qu'elle vient le voir et là
bas contrairement à la réputation de
tante yvonne et oncle charles qui jamais
n'aurait imaginé jamais en laisant à
imaginer recevant une femme nue avec les
plumes et des bananes et la reçoivent
dans leur loge et le général toujours
très courtois se lève pour me laisser
son siège et lui offre une petite croix
de lorraine en or là ça sera ça râle
symboles sont un symbole magnifique
avant qu'elle ne soit décoré
on va peut-être voir les images des
premières images me dit-on dans
l'oreillette de cette cérémonie qui
devrait débuter dans quelques minutes
maintenant une cérémonie à laquelle ont
été conviés deux mille personnes
personnalités à nos minimes qui sont
rassemblés vous le voyez devant le
panthéon un immense gigantesque tapis
rouge a été déroulé rue soufflot et sur
la place et on voit là le cercueil le
cénotaphe de joséphine baker car elle
n'est pas son corps n'est pas dans ce
cercueil c'est un cercueil symbolique
mais dans ce cercueil il y a quatre
poignées de terre symbolique
correspondant aux quatre endroits où
joséphine baker à a passé sa vie une
poignée de terre de saint louis dans le
missouri aux états unis où elle est née
il y en a aussi de paris de monaco et
puis de la dordogne où se trouvait son
château son fameux château de 2000 ans
doubs où elle a élevé ses 12 enfants
adoptifs
ses douze enfants adoptifs à cette
famille arc-en-ciel fait aussi aussi de
la légende du mythe de joséphine baker
et de l'engagement qu'elle avait mis
favoriser le elle rêvait d'un constituer
une planète réconcilier parce que ses 12
enfants des noirs des asiatiques
de tout de toute religion également un
alors la cérémonie à laquelle on va
assister en quelques minutes maintenant
est prévue pour durer une heure et demie
comme le veut l'usagé
normalement le
cercueil remontera
de la célèbre artère rue soufflot jusque
jusqu'au panthéon
le corps de joséphine baker et donc est
resté est toujours à monaco au cimetière
marin de monaco et d'après nos
informations le cercueil devrait être
porté par six membres de l'armée de
l'air et de l'espace dont elle fut
membre ça aussi l'abonné devrait mettre
son uniforme absolument décoration y
compris pour aller des cérémonies aux
états unis mais quand elle a accompagné
fait qu alan martin luther king
est-ce qu'on peut revoir ces images même
si pour l'instant le plan fx mais qu'on
soit un peu dans dans l'esprit de ce qui
va arriver
ça sera une cérémonie très très
solennelle empreinte certainement de
beaucoup d'émotion christine clerc parce
qu'il ya les proches
et puis c'est l'histoire qui parle oui
et encore oui c'est un personnage qu'on
redécouvre qu'on avait vu peut-être avec
une certaine légèreté et dont on
redécouvre la profondeur de l'engagement
il faut remercier registre de break
était je crois n'est ni serveur initiale
de miss en 2013 cette bonne idée ce qui
a surpris un monsieur très sérieux
mobilis est et puis finalement grâce à
lui on a on a redécouvert joséphine
baker absolument il ya une pétition va
le préciser un qui est aussi motivé
aujourd'hui l'entrée de joséphine baker
au panthéon c'est une pétition qui a été
signée par plus de 40 pays wilson et je
combats osez joséphine pour son entrée
au panthéon
ce qu'on peut dire également en voyant
ces images c'est que
le cénotaphe donc ce cercueil symbolique
sera rejoindra celui de maurice genevoix
qui lui aussi a fait son entrée au
panthéon il ya un an
et
cercueil sera situé dans l'allée en face
de celle où leur peau de jean moulin
andré malraux simone veil et son époux
ainsi que les révolutionnaires de 1789
simone veil n'avait accepté à face à
faire accepter d'entrer que si son mari
était à ses côtés
voilà tout le monde se prépare pour
cette cérémonie
joséphine baker et la sixième femme à
entrer au panthéon sur 80 personnalités
qui sont aujourd'hui accueillis
on va voir si la régie julien qu'une
elle peut nous montrer le visuel
fabriqués par kevin hébuterne qui nous
montre ces cinq femmes qui sont d'ores
et déjà accueilli par les illustres en
1907 il s'agissait de sophie berthelot
qui était femme de marcelin berthelot
qui était un chimiste et hommes
politiques
c'est la première en trente et une femme
deux autres et comme femme évolue entre
elles n'étaient pas scientifique elle
même et puis en 1995 ce sera le tour de
marie curie en 2015 deux femmes
résistante et déportée entre au panthéon
il s'agit de vous le voyez sur ces
images germaine tillion et geneviève de
gaulle anthonioz que vous souhaitiez
tout à l'heure qui signe clair qui est
la nièce du général de gaulle et la
dernière entrée au panthéon c'était
simone veil en 2018 qui a été accueilli
au panthéon des grands hommes un chef
d'état c'est toujours un pari difficile
que de prononcer le discours après le
fameux entre ici jean moulin andré
malraux
christine clerc je le disais c'est donc
la sixième femme à entrer au panthéon a
choisi film de guerre c'est aussi la
première femme noire à y trouver sa
place
c'est un événement tout à fait
symbolique c'est la décision des manuels
mâcon qui s'est tu et manuel mâcon qui a
tranché et a décidé que c'était une
belle décision de réconciliation à une
époque où chacun revendique que ça va
sarah son sexe
son identité entre guillemets alors elle
a prouvé qu'on pouvait avoir plusieurs
plusieurs races plusieurs identités donc
vous pouvez venir de plusieurs mondes et
unir ces monde sait ce qu'elle a voulu
faire en adoptant ses 12 enfants
d'ailleurs c'était la symbolique qui lui
tenait à coeur et qui finalement
représente la france puisque la france
est une terre d'accueil quand on regarde
les noms des grands hommes des grandes
femmes qui sont en pente et en os ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs hier j'étais à une
cérémonie à l'académie française je
voyais toutes les statues il ya beaucoup
de non dits verts beaucoup d'heures mais
pas beaucoup de femmes mais ça commence
mais c'est la france c'est l'image de la
france est vraiment c'est une c'est une
belle idée l'aveyron est ce qu'on peut
considérer que c'est également compte
tenu du contexte aujourd'hui
un geste politique très fort du chef de
l'état une éthique très fort oui bien
sûr
réconciliation de diversité nous sommes
tous d'hiver c'est aussi ça veut dire ne
pas entrer dans une catégorie joséphine
baker n'est pas n'est pas que noir elle
avait de quoi qu'elle avait un père
métis ou une maman et elle n'est pas que
américaine elle est américaine et
française elle n'est pas que chanteuse
de musique où elle est aussi l ai
beaucoup de choses à poil nous pouvons
tous être beaucoup de choses à la fois
d'avoir plusieurs engagements plusieurs
et reed plusieurs héritage et
le choix entre plusieurs à venir à ne
pas être amené toujours à une condition
étroite quand on considère que en tout
cas certain que c'est une récupération
politique d' emmanuel macron à cinq mois
de l'échéance présidentielle ces
cérémonies ont été des récupérations
politiques à partir du moment où chacun
aimait ses choix personne qu'on veut
honorer jean françois hollande avait
fait entrer geneviève de gaulle est bon
on peut toujours dire ça bien sûr on
peut toujours dire ça que vous l'avez
vous fait avant
si vous nous rejoignez en ce moment en
direct sur figaro live et sur notre
chaîne youtube nous allons vous faire
vivre en direct
l'entrée de joséphine baker au panthéon
une cérémonie qui devrait avoir lieu
dans quelques minutes présidée par le
chef de l'état emmanuel macron en
présence de 2000 personnes qui sont
rassemblés à l'extérieur et en partie à
l'intérieur
vous le voyez sur ces images le
cénotaphe qui est le cercueil symbolique
dans lequel
sont disposés on va dire quatre poignées
de terre qui sont originaires des lieux
quatre lieux différents dans lesquels
joséphine baker a vécu au long de sa vie
à la fois saint louis dans le missouri
monaco paris et la dordogne où se trouve
son chalet des milandes où elle a
longtemps vécu
le cercueil sera porté par six
militaires de l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace jusqu'à l'intérieur du panthéon
une femme d'ailleurs devrait suivre ce
ce cercueil et elle aura un coussin sur
lequel seront disposées les décorations
nombreuses des joséphine baker qui sont
au nombre de quatre je crois ou cinq
dons à la médaille de chevalier
de la légion d'honneur d'honneur il ya
aussi je vais retrouver des résistances
celle de la résistance
je vais vous préciser ça tout de suite
parce que c'est
le plus grand honneur pour elle ça je
crois que ça avait été d'être reçu par
le général
et d'être accueilli par lui et ensuite
il avoue lui même l'aider quand elle a
eu des difficultés financières on va
l'aider lui trouver un logement tout cas
lui et puis aussi à ces graisses de
manac grace de monaco évidemment mais
était à se reloger
à monaco alors je vois là je suis
précise maintenant donc une aviatrice
suivre un coussin dans les mains avec
les cinq décorations reçues par
joséphine baker donc la croix de
chevalier de la légion d'honneur qu'elle
avait aussi en 1961 la croix de guerre
de 1939-1945 avec palmes de bronze aussi
également en 1961 et puis elle a eu en
1946 la médaille de la résistance
française avec rosette la médaille
commémorative des services volontaires
de la france libre et la médaille
commémorative française de la guerre
1939 1945
on nous précise également que dans ce
programme et cette cérémonie
les images des grands moments de sa vie
seront projetés sur la façade du
panthéon et résonneront également
quelques-unes de ses chansons on imagine
qu'on entendra j'ai deux amours
évidemment et puis les portes du temple
républicain s'ouvriront au son de la
musique du compositeur pascal dusapin
compositeur dont la musique avait déjà
accompagné en ces lieux l'an dernier
l'entrée de l'écrivain maurice genevoix
emmanuel macron prononcera un discours
depuis l'intérieur du panthéon en
présence de nombreux élèves d'écoles de
collèges et lycées
et puis comme je vous le préciser tout à
l'heure le cénotaphe donc ce cercueil
que vous voyez en ce moment cercueils
symboliques ira rejoindre celui de donc
maurice genevoix dans le caveau numéro
13 dans une allée située en face de
celle où reposent jean moulin andré
malraux simoneau veille et son époux et
les révolutionnaires de 1789
c'est intéressant de
si emmanuel macron est effectivement
présence de d'élèves de jeunes ont ils
assisté à la fois un événement comme
celui-là et de rappeler à la mémoire de
tous et des plus jeunes en particulier
le destin et l'engagement d'une
personnalité comme celle de joséphine
baker oui on vient d'ailleurs
beaucoup de français viennent d'ailleurs
on peut en plus être à la fois dans ce
qui paraît léger les plumes la danse et
et puis dans l'engagement risque au
péril de sa vie
ce qui me gênait pas au contraire
100% peur
on peut être plusieurs plusieurs choses
à la fois et n'est pas nécessaire d'être
forcément si vert en uniforme ou dans un
ami selon elle pour pour arriver au plus
haut niveau du dévouement à la patrie
il ya mille façons de l'être c'est ça
qu'il ou qu'elle nous enseigne et je
pense que pour les enfants c'est une
belle découverte aussi il n'y a pas on
va pas fractionné
est ce qu'on peut dire que dans son
engagement dont on disait que jusqu'à la
fin de sa vie il ne cessera pas elle a
été une militante anti raciste vraiment
intraitable est ce qu'on peut considérer
que c'est la ségrégation qu'elle a vécu
aux états unis c'est ce qui a forgé
selon vous de le socle
indestructible de ses engagements qu'ils
ont accompagnés jusqu'au bout oui et
puis le choc quand elle arrive en france
que l'état cueilli on la met pas au
dernier rang on l'a même pas dans les
soutes du navire elle est accueillie on
l'invite tout de suite au restaurant
elle est tout étonné parce qu'on lui
sert quelque chose à manger ce qui
n'était pas le cas aux états unis et
découvre que c'est que la fraternité
et ça c'est c'est un choc formidable
pour elle est là elle en tire une joie
moi ce qui m'émerveille c'est sa joie
vraiment ce qu'elles le sont mais
d'ailleurs cette joie là dont vous
parlez c'est ce qui l'a portée pour
retourner aux états unis croyant que la
gloire et le succès en europe allait lui
rouvrir les portes aux états unis et que
finalement ce dont elle avait souffert
enfant allait disparaître et en fait pas
du tout à chaque fois qu'elle a remis
les pieds aux etats-unis à chaque fois
l'un d'eux a été blessé
elle a ramené aussi à son enfance allait
m'emmener beaucoup de souvenirs qui
remontaient à la surface mais
effectivement la cérémonie avec martin
luther king s'était c'était un marqueur
mais
sa joie de paris de danse et on raconte
que quand elle revenait on pourrait
penser que l'été puis après une tournée
oui mais chanter matin midi et soir le
cd couche à trois au matin elle revenait
au château elle réveiller les enfants
faire la fête pour chanter pour danser
c'est donc elle leur a appris la joie
c'était pas même si pareille qu'elle
était merde quand même pour ce faire
assez faire louis mais cela n'empêchait
pas la gaieté
ferme mais juste
d'ailleurs c'est ce château dont on
parle qui est complètement en accord
avec sa personnalité elle en a fait un
endroit elle ne l'avait pas simplement
ses enfants il y avait une communauté
qui vivaient sur place il y avait des
visiteurs des touristes qui venaient
grands elle voulait en faire un monde
sans des parcs de loisirs
tout à la fois je lisais qu'il y avait
la queue des voitures qu'il y avait des
embouteillages pour accéder aux lieux
qu'est-ce qu'elle y faisait qu est ce qu
elle est présente un des premiers parcs
de loisirs finalement il présentait
beaucoup de choses mais je pense qu'on
venait on venait surtout pour elle ou
pour voir les enfants pour la voir et
tout huila jeu semblait lui être acquis
parce qu'elle est allée à la rencontre
des gens aller prendre un café très
volontiers enfin elle posait pas à la la
star c'est pas parce qu'elle avait
choisi d'habiter un château qu'elle oui
il s'était dirigé en châtelaine
loin de loin des gens de villages au
contraire je crois qu'elle est un
commerce jacques à l'époque où un
village
du sud ouest de la france qui va arriver
cette tribu mais non ils ont ils ont
très bien pris et
on peut dire que joséphine baker a une
existence totalement romanesque oui on
aurait voulu créer son personnage on n'y
serait pas arrivé si bien quelle réalité
aussi il ya des choses
qu'on on a du mal à concevoir
aujourd'hui parce que d'abord bon quand
elle commence à être indépendante très
jeunes parce qu'il faut bien qu'elle
gagne de quoi de quoi manger et mais
enfin bon je crois qu'elle se marie et
dès le premier mariage sévère 13,4 me
sens très jeune très jeune et puis après
elle part et puis elle est marie parlant
trouve un autre et puis et puis après
ils vont trouver un troisième qui après
leur avoir
une vie incroyable et puis elle s'engage
à un moment quand elle est
en france elle est en elle est devenue
une star elle s'engage pour faire un
tour pour aller jusqu'à moscou et puis
il finit tapis puis
tout à coup elle a trouvé un nouvel
amour elle est repartie s'est satisfait
de liberté et se mélangent
d'apparenté légèreté et d'engagement
au prix de sa vie enfin et toujours
sidérant il ya c'est là qu'il faut tout
sans cesse faire un effort pour se
replonger dans une époque quand même
très très différente de la nôtre se
mélangent extraordinaire de de liberté
de gaieté et en même temps de sens du
sacrifice d'un sens du sacrifice
justement qu'il a qui l'a fait s'engager
dans la résistance on le disait un petit
peu plus tôt et c'est ce pourquoi elle
est aujourd'hui
accueillis au sein de du panthéon
on s'est un peu en détail et les actions
qu'elle a menées quand elle s'est
engagée dans le contre espionnage gizeh
qu'elle transportait dans ses sous
vêtements des documents écrits à l'encré
sympathique je crois qu'effectivement
comme les têtes invité partout y compris
dans des soirs où il y avait des
officiers nazis
bon elle entend des choses qu'elle
allait aux toilettes et elle ne dit sur
des petits bouts de papier qu'elle
mettait dans l'ourlet de sa robe puis
après quand elle rentre elle mettait
tout ça en forme et elle a transmis je
crois des informations qui ont été très
précieuse pour les alliés et pour les
américains et pour les pour les français
ensuite si bien qu'on l'a renvoyé en
mission et la tournée
la tournée de la chanteuse danseuse
joséphine baker était aussi la tournée
d'une espionne pour le camp
franco américain mais même je crois les
nazis ne soupçonnais absolument pas
évidemment je pouvais être une espionne
ils étaient séduits par part par le fait
qu'elle était star et qu'elle faisait le
show oui on peut penser qu'elle n'aurait
pas beaucoup plu à hitler qui ne voulait
pas de noirs nul pas mais enfin les
officiers nazis elle n'aura plus sa a pu
être très utile
vous êtes nombreux à nous à nous suivre
sur les réseaux sociaux du figaro sur le
chat du figaro.fr beaucoup d'entre vous
parle de la deûle entrée au panthéon
d'une grande dame on pouvait la définir
comme une grande dame joséphine baker
qu'est ce que c'est une grande dame oui
c'est quelqu'un qui met ses valeurs au
dessus tout je crois
il ne met pas sa vanille des personnels
qui ne met pas ses intérêts personnels
moi j'ai été très frappée de découvrir
je ne savais pas que j'avais fait ses
tournées sans être payés en refusant
d'être payé puisqu'elle le faisait alors
ensuite vers la france lui devait bien
un peu des deux quand elle quand elle se
trouvait a ruiné mes grandes dames c'est
peut-être la générosité sans le faire
remarquer évidemment on a l'ap a su à ce
moment là il a su que bien plus tard
mais elle donnait tout donner tout son
talent en son temps je vois son corps
oui oui
vous le voyez sur sur ces images en
direct depuis paris et et le panthéon la
place du panthéon sont rassemblées près
de 2000 personnes pour assister à
l'entrée de de joséphine baker au
panthéon aujourd'hui
c'est la sixième femme à entrer au
panthéon
parmi 80 personnalités qui sont déjà
présentes parmi les illustres c'est
comme ça qu'on dit christine clerc les
illustre donc ce sont des personnalités
qui se sont illustrées dans l'histoire
par leurs actions et aujourd'hui c'est
un événement très important qu'on a
décidé de vous faire vivre en direct je
suis donc avec christine clerc qui est
grand reporter prix albert-londres
écrivain auteur d'ouvragés sur
l'histoire la politique et des ouvrages
sur le général de gaulle en particulier
qui connaît très bien la résistance et
qui nous parle depuis le début de cet
entretien de joséphine baker cette femme
extraordinaire
à la vie romanesque dont on aurait pu
faire et écrire un roman et la cérémonie
devrait débuter dans quelques minutes
maintenant elle est très en retard
puisqu'il ya déjà un quart d'heure de
retard par rapport au début de ce qui
nous avait été annoncé ce cercueil qui
est un cénotaphe je le disais un
cercueil symbolique qui ne contient pas
le corps de joséphine baker qui reste
inhumé enterré au cimetière marin de
monaco et qui va être porté par six
militaires issus de l'armée de l'air et
de l'espace à laquelle avait appartenu
joséphine baker qui sera suivi de ces
décorations nombreuses de ses
engagements au sein de l'armée et du
contre-espionnage et du renseignement
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale car
on le rappelle en plus d'avoir été une
star du music hall la première grande
star non art mondial elle a été engagée
comme résistante et espionne au sein de
l'armée française et c'est ce pourquoi
aujourd'hui elle est célébrée christine
clerc qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui
d'une personnalité comme joséphine baker
est ce qu on pourrait aujourd'hui avoir
une figure de la même trempe que cette
femme oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce
elle revenait en danseuse avec sa
ceinture de bananes elle choquerait
beaucoup et on apprendrait pas au
sérieux
c'est difficile de ne pas enfermer
quelqu'un dans une case comme nous le
faisons beaucoup aujourd'hui comme nous
avons beaucoup tendance à le faire et on
pourrait voir aussi l'adoption de tous
ces enfants qui est quand même un rêve
d'harmonie mondial de réconciliation
mondiale et en plus elle a réussi parce
qu apparemment ça s'est bien passé un
moment son mari de l'époque disait
faudrait que des garçons ou que défi
parce que si on à garçons et filles on
va avoir des histoires d'amour des
histoires de rivalité s'arrêter pour un
terme et finalement elle a quand même
pris dix garçons et deux filles bon
apparemment ce serait apparemment ça
s'est très bien passé parce qu'elle leur
a transmis
de l' enthousiasme et des valeurs et pas
et parlent pas la jalousie et à l'envi
du moins qu'on sache
j'entendais justement le témoignage d'un
de ses fils auteur d'un ouvrage
récemment je crois que c'est bryan qui a
écrit un livre
dont il fait la promotion ces derniers
temps il racontait combien entre frères
et soeurs même quand on en avait un qui
faisait des bêtises aucun d'entre eux ne
se dénonçait et il préféré rendre folle
leur mère qu'ils ne savaient pas qui
elle devait s'adresser voilà la
cérémonie a débuté mais ils ont toujours
gardé cette façon de gérer
les conflits sans jamais dénoncer qui
que ce soit on va laisser vivre ces
images vous le voyez avec le cénotaphe
de joséphine baker qui va entrer au
panthéon
le roi très vif alors pour l'instant on
me dit que le son n'est pas disponible
sur les images de la fp on espère le
récupérer rapidement et quand même à
voir l'atmosphère qui se passe qui ce
qui est qui se déroule en ce moment
avec cette mise en scène pour cette
cérémonie très solennelle
c'est l'aviation
lasseube le très très vif
l'oreille mais elle a aimé
pour l'instant donc nous n'avons
toujours pas le son
maquereau est arrivé
probablement
nos micros sont ouverts pour l'instant
tant que nous n'avons pas le son de la
fps qui est bien dommage donc vous le
voyez sur ces images six membres de
l'armée de l'air et de l'espace dont
joséphine baker fut membre bon porté
le cercueil jusque
dans l'enceinte du panthéon à
l'intérieur du panthéon
emmanuel macron est à l'intérieur du
temple républicain
il devrait prononcer un discours
évidemment très attendu discours très
attendu que qu'on commencera à la fin de
la cérémonie christine clerc si vous
êtes d'accord
cause de cette erreur de discrimination
réalise notre âme et notre corps
[Musique]
prix
elle se marie une première fois en 1919
elle a 13 ans
l'année suivante forte de sa selle
détermination elle parvient à enchaîner
des petits rôle de danseuse
[Musique]
et il débute sur scène 1924 dans une
revue de music-hall à broadway nous or
le style de joséphine mélange de grâce
et de comics séduit déjà
car anthony d'hadley reggane une
amoureuse du jazz est la compagne du
fondateur de la revue [ __ ] à paris la
remarque et l'invita traversée de
l'atlantique en direction de la france
le 2 octobre 1925 au théâtre des champs
elysées à paris
joséphine déclenché l'enthousiasmé avec
le premier spectacle de la revue [ __ ]
c'est un triomphe
les personnalités du tout paris se
préfecture
les critiques sont élogieuses mais
certains y voient un spectacle obscène
[Musique]
c'est aux folies bergères qu'elle revêt
la fameuse ceinture de bananes qui l'a
remplacé
tout en se jouant de clichés du
colonialisme elle s'impose comme la
nouvelle égérie des années folles
fascinant les artistes comme picasso
mènerait calder
elle part faire le tour des villes
européennes
en autriche une mobilisation a lieu pour
interdire son spectacle mais la tournée
en europe est une réussite
à son retour à paris
c'est la consécration
la danseuse afro-américaine triomphe sur
les planches des folies bergères et du
casino de paris où elle chante j'ai deux
amours composé par vincent spettel
elle devient la première star noire les
icônes mondiales le poème à rs 1
viennent de londres à tunis
elle tourne au cinéma avec jean gabin
et en 1937 elle acquiert la nationalité
française
[Musique]
va fois par jour ou par 12 elle
on est bien sûr très amoureux
me propose une ville de rennes
pour que jaune d'or
[Musique]
dans l'eau
moi j'en perdais de
lessiveuse
qu'ils n'entendront
on
[Musique]
la déclaration de la guerre en septembre
joséphine rencontre jacques a ptet chef
du contre-espionnage militaire
chargé de recruter d'honorables
correspondants
des personnalités bénévoles digne de
confiance
susceptible de se rendre partout sans
éveiller les soupçons
pour recueillir des renseignements sur
l'activité des agents allemands
joséphine lui répond capitaine ne
suis-je pas devenu l'enfant chéri des
parisiens
ils m'ont tout donné en particulier leur
coeur
je leur ai donné le mien
je suis prêt à leur donner aujourd'hui
ma vie vous pouvez disposer de moi comme
vous l'entendez
dès les premiers mois de la guerre elle
effectué plusieurs tournées pour motiver
les troupes
elle a plus de 4000 filleul de guerre
chaque soir elle assure à ses frais la
gestion d'un centre d'accueil de
réfugiés à la gare du nord
sous la france occupée elles entrent
immédiatement en résistance contre les
nazis et refuse de chanter à paris tant
que les allemands sont présents
pour l'ennemi elle reste l'artiste et si
on alors le maghreb et les pays arabes
de marrakech à damas
sous couvert de ses tours de chant et
glam des informations en les dissimulant
dans ses partitions
aux milandes
elle cache des résistants et la famille
de jean lion son ex mari qui était juif
ses activités lui vaudront la médaille
de la résistance
reçu des mains du colonel boucheron de
boissoudy et les insignes de chevalier
de la légion d'honneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ami entends tu le vol noir des corbeaux
sur nos plaines
[Musique]
ma vie entre tous ces cris sourds du
pays qu'on enchaîne
[Musique]
les parties
ml foncer là dedans
soit là
du sang et des larmes
monté il descendait
nous sommes tél
c'est ici
oui
mais que là
[Musique]
suite
sinon
oh
bravo
ils feraient
analyse
on vit
les gens
ici
chez nous
si chacun sait ce qu'il veut ce qu'il
fait quand tu passes
ami si tu tombes un ami sort de l'ombre
à ta place
au soleil sur les routes
sifflé compagnon
mm
[Musique]
et
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après la guerre elle tente de renouer
avec la scène américaine
mais elle se heurte à nouveau à la
ségrégation raciale
dans un club mur qui est très sélect on
refuse de la servir
joséphine baker mobilise la société pour
les droits front américain
les demandes à un huissier de constater
le racisme qu'elle a subi
[Musique]
le lendemain des militants viennent avec
des pancartes pour bloquer l'entrée du
club
[Musique]
la sphère devient médiatique
joséphine baker et décréter ennemis des
etats-unis est fiché au fbi comme
activiste
qu'elle s'engage dès lors pour le
mouvement des droits civiques
c'est le début de son combat contre le
racisme
combat qu'il mènera toute sa vie
en 1963
elle participe à la marche de washington
organisé par martin luther king
elle est à ses côtés et prend la parole
vêtu de son uniforme de sous lieutenant
de l'armée de l'air
marié à jo bouillon
musicien et chef d'orchestre français
elle fait du château des milandes
elle veut à l'image de sa vision du
monde
un village de la fraternité
elle y fonde une famille qu'elle
appellera sa tribu arc en ciel
douze enfants de toutes origines adoptée
dans le monde
pendant plus de 15 ans
elle n'a de cesse de voyager et de se
produire partout dans le monde pour
subvenir aux dépenses du domaine
[Musique]
oh
go
[Musique]
le temps
si lilo
ça
[Musique]
mais
il sait
[Musique]
ouais
vous
[Musique]
novembre un jeu
y est 9e tendrement
non mourir un jour
c'est un tout petit enfant
cinq autres la nu ces deux langues
qu'ils s'ennuyaient israël et ses bas
et j'ai voulu
qu'ils soient choyés
dans un foyer
[Musique]
villa
où
les rangs
à
des enfants
[Musique]
ici
g
qui est franchement
[Musique]
oh
pour salim
[Musique]
on
non
vous
[Musique]
pour moi
les jantes
mo
oh
[Musique]
les
et
la
et couleurs de la nuit le deux autres
sont les salles du jour le quatrième est
cool a du sens le dernier volet du
soleil mais tous les 500 mais en france
les mots que deux mamans les aime tous
contents
où
c'est mon vélo
ans
[Musique]
témoignage
ans
nous
ici on
vous
il
[Musique]
oh
on
hélas
[Musique]
ans
les agents
il
on
[Musique]
et
je viendrai
les lots
et
[Musique]
non
oh
[Applaudissements]
aidé par la croix rouge
elle remonte sur la scène de l'olympia
en 1968
l'année suivante
jean claude brialy l'accueille dans son
cabaret
elle continue d'honorer des engagements
sur les scènes européennes
grâce de monaco
présentes lors de l'incident dans le
club new yorkais où on avait refusé de
la servir en raison de sa couleur de
peau
mais une ville à sa disposition
villa que joséphine baker rachète
quelques années après
à sa mort ami fidèle
grace de monaco verra surtout ses
enfants
avec toute la bienveillance qui l'animé
le 9 avril 1975
le rideau tombe devant une salle
enthousiaste
joséphine baker célèbre ses 50 ans de
carrière
lors d'une rétrospective
joséphine à bobino
le lendemain matin
victime d'une attaque cérébrale
elle est transportée dans un coma
profond à la salpêtrière
elle sera la première femme
afro-américaine
à recevoir les honneurs militaires lors
de ses funérailles à paris
[Musique]
je n'oublie y ait jamais
cranham
les roues monsieur
né vous
mais dom
[Musique]
on est qu'au delà des mers la barre sur
le ciel clair
il existe une cité aux séjours ont
chanté
des jeux les grands à benoît hacot soit
20 cents bateaux mon espoir
deux amours
ont veillé paris
mon coeur est ravi
à st
les bains
mais un fort vent
ce qui rend sont
bottes aux pieds
[Musique]
un jour
nous aimons
lee
un mot
mon pays ma vie
[Musique]
on
ce qui montre
[Musique]
tout entier
le croiser un jour
oh
j'ai eu 2
amour
[Musique]
monthey
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
e
où
bouh
[Musique]
oh
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
harry rady son pari
c'est sur la terre
[Musique]
le mes amours c'est lui le parent qui
vous plaît
le feu lundi en
était pas pour i télé
[Musique]
j'ai toujours essayé de ne pas me mettre
dans un cat gorie d'une grande artiste
non je pense que je suis une personne
qui a été
adoptée par la france
ça m'a surtout développer le sens
humaniste et c'est cela pour moi le plus
important de ma vie
[Musique]
il remporte d'une tournée en egypte un
chef de quatre millions et demi de
francs destiné à la résistance
[Musique]
où
pourquoi avez vous accepté d'entrer dans
les services secrets
pour défendre la france
au mondial la dignité humaine
[Musique]
moi
quand je pense à ça
moi je pense à ces réseaux
qu'ils nous en souffrent
je n'ai plus ni la vie ni dieu qui nous
a fait
le news en tu mets
sans plus
quand je prends ça
quand je pense à ça
quand je pense à ceux qui souffrent si
loin
je voudrais les réunir qui de me
retrouver
à tout jamais à tout jamais
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma folie
mua en devises à compliquer vêtue et
continue à l' ukraine drowned world
adventures
[Musique]
dudu
non
du
[Musique]
on ne le fera pas
me pose autres
grimpeur
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu cette idée parce que j'ai vu
tellement de
l'incompréhension entre les accumule les
soi-disant adultes et il est sûr qu'avec
nos petits-enfants innocent il pourrait
bien exemple absolu de la fraternité et
mondial ce n'est qu'en france qu'on
pourrait donner une telle exemple de
tout ces petits enfants au nom des
cadres one man et vivent ici vraiment
aux frères
aurillac
que l'ordre revienne sans voir
où ils veulent
delage
avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
et
héroïne de guerre
combattante
danseuses
chanteuses
noires défendant les noirs mais d'abord
femmes défendant le genre humain
américaine
et française
joséphine baker mais mena tant de
combats
avec
liberté
légèreté
gaieté
fulgurante de beauté de lucidité dans un
siècle d'égarement elle fit à chaque
tournant de l'histoire les justes choix
distinguant toujours les lumières des
ténèbres et pourtant
rien
rien n'était écrit
saint louis
naître d'une mère blanchisseuse et d'un
père inconnu
habiter une cabane au toit percé
à seulement huit ans servir une famille
riche et blanche pour nourrir la sienne
pauvre et noir
être battu
maltraité fuir
assisté impuissant aux émeutes raciales
et à leur cohorte de morts se marier à
13 ans ne pas se résigner
danser danser pour vivre vivre pour
danser à saint louis à la nouvelle
orléans puis à philadelphie envoûté le
public par son énergie et son humour
gagné bredou et théâtre des possibles
rencontré caroline 2 les créatrices de
revient en europe effet relevé devant
soi tous les rideaux céder toutes les
portes
tomber toutes les barrières
paris
quand joséphine baker arrive en france
paris est une fête
elle n'a pas 20 ans
1 et folles
années de danse et de musique
années de nuit et d'ivresse ou se noie
joseph kessel ignorant qu'un jour il
écrira le chant des partisans
si dans cette france partagée entre soif
de liberté et préjugés coloniaux
l'enfant de saint louis se distingue
c'est parce qu'elle invente
des le fameux soir du 2 octobre 1925 au
théâtre des champs elysées un numéro qui
dépasse les contradictions française de
l'époque
les concepteurs de la revue [ __ ]
imagine-t-il pour elle une danse du
ventre
fantasmes d'exotisme sauvage
elle s'y livre
mais en gonflant les joues
en écartant les genoux de sorte que le
comique détourne bientôt le sensuel
lui demande-t-on de danser nu vêtue
d'une simple ceinture de bananes d'auray
elle y consent
mais écorne l'érotisme à coups de
grimaces de gestes saccadés balles et
les clichés d'un revers de manche hérail
l'imagier negra par ses roulements
d'yeux moqueurs
les stéréotypes
joséphine baker les endosse mais elle
les bouscule les égratigne les tournant
burlesque sublime
esprit des lumières ridiculisant les
préjugés colonialiste sur des notes de
sidney bechet
le triomphe est immédiat
folies bergères escaliers mythique du
casino de paris
scène de toutes les capitales
européennes
les danses syncopé de la perle noire
contrepoint insolent à la basse continue
du racisme enchante la france et bientôt
toute l'europe à une vitesse inouïe
la voici un jour chanteuse sur des
succès de vincent scotto un autre
actrice devenant ou jouer donnant la
réplique à jean gabin cli dévalant les
champs elysées guépard tenus en laisse
au volant d'un cabriolet recouvert de
cuir de serpent
aux côtés d'un homme une nuit
au bras d'une femme une autre elle qui a
deux amours
en quelques années seulement
joséphine baker forge sa légende
elle épouse la scène
impose sa liberté
entre dans l'imaginaire et dans
l'intimité des français
par son insouciance
jamais inconsciente
son courage toujours gai
cette légèreté ou relais de tristesse
car bord ceux qui ont déjà vécu
l'américaine réfugié à paris devient
l'incarnation de l'esprit français est
le symbole d'une époque
rêve coeur le grand dans l'oise
30 novembre
il y à 84 ans jour pour jour
je sais fine revient d'une tournée
difficile aux états unis la ségrégation
et y est plus sévère que jamais elle se
marie avec jean lion et devient alors
officiellement
citoyenne française
les français m'ont tout donné
je suis prête alors offrir aujourd'hui
ma vie
joséphine baker ne considère pas sa
nouvelle nationalité comme un droit
mais avant tout comme un devoir une
conquête de chaque jour
aussi ce goût tels toute entière à sa
nouvelle patrie et à la défense de ces
valeurs là voici militants indéfectible
de la ligue internationale contre
l'antisémitisme
dès 1938 puis officier de l'armée de
l'air
servant comme infirmière dans le cadre
d'actions organisée par la croix rouge
sur la ligne maginot elle donne des
concerts mémorables en soutien au moral
des troupes
alors que la blitzkrieg menée par
l'allemagne nazie et frais l'europe
joséphine decker elle veut faire plus
trop quand les feux de la rampe pour la
flamme de la résistance
elle devient avant même le 18 juin
honorable correspondante
et sert son nouveau pays au péril de sa
vie
protégeant résistants et juifs dans sa
propriété des milandes transformer en
antenne radio recevant sur son lit
d'hôpital à casablanca tout ce que le
maghreb compte d'officiers de la france
libre parcourant l'afrique et l'europe
pour transmettre des informations
confidentielles écrite à l'encré
sympathique sur ses partitions ou cachés
dans ses robes traversant le désert
angie pour galvaniser les soldats
préparant le débarquement de provence
joséphine joue un rôle à ce point
décisif
qu'elle se voit décerner la médaille de
la résistance
surtout
l'insigne qu'elle préférera entre tous
une petite croix de lorraine en or
reçu des mains mêmes du général de
gaulle en 1943 et qu'elle finit pourtant
par vendre pour reverser l'argent aux
oeuvres de la résistance
puis en 1961 la croix de guerre avec
palme
et la légion d'honneur remise par le
général 20 c'est cela joséphine un
combat pour la france libre sans calcul
sans quête de gloire
dévoués à nos idéaux
washington
28 août
alors qui connaît du lait après l'aller
la libération elle aurait pu comme
beaucoup d'autres s'installer dans la
célébrité
joséphine baker uniforme de l'armée de
l'air en étendard prend la parole devant
les milliers de militants des droits
civiques qui attendent le discours du
pasteur martin luther king
ce jour là
qu'elle définit comme le plus beau de sa
vie
et pour elle l'aboutissement d'une
longue lutte
s'avançant vers le pupitre
sans doute repenser tel à la petite
fille qui punit par ses maîtres blancs
pour avoir cassé une assiette s'était
fait ébouillanté les mains
au temps où même la vedette qu'elle est
et se voyait interdire l'accès à des
hôtels aux états unis à cette soirée
où sous les yeux de grace kelly
qui ne l'oubliera jamais elle s'était
vue refuser
le service aux stores club un grand
restaurant new yorkais
au quartier de harlem qui avait organisé
en son honneur en 1951 un becker des
pour la remercier d'avoir ouvert ses
concerts aussi bien aux noirs comme
blancs aux milliers de femmes et
d'hommes qui avait rejoint ses combats
alors
évoquant dans son discours son
invitation prochaine à la maison blanche
joséphine baker oui à coup sûr
se souvient de tout cela
et déclare à la foule
ce n'est pas la femme de couleur
la noire qui ira là-bas
c'est une femme
joséphine baker ne défendez pas une
couleur de peau
elle portait une certaine idée de
l'homme et militer pour la liberté de
chacun
sa cause et l universalisme l'unité du
genre humain
l'égalité de tous avant l'identité de
chacun
l'hospitalité pour toutes les
différences réunis par une même volonté
une même dignité
l'émancipation
contre l'assignation
ont cela en tout cela
devant le lincoln memorial médaille de
la résistance à graffer sur son revers
de veste elle était plus française que
jamais
infiniment juste
infiniment fraternelle
infiniment de france
et que nul aujourd'hui ne fasse mentir
ou ne détourne son combat universel ce
n'était pas un combat pour s'affirmer
comme noir avant de se définir comme
américaine ou française
ce n'était pas un combat pour dire les
réductibles it et de la cause noire non
mais bien pour être citoyenne libre
digne
complètement
résolument
dordogne
15 mars
malgré les tournées répéter
malgré le courage et l appel télévisé de
brigitte bardot
malgré le soutien de généreux donateurs
joséphine baker est expulsé de sa
célèbre propriété du périgord noir le
château des milandes
loin des plumes et des paillettes elle
se réfugie avec ses enfants à paris
avant de gagner
monseigneur
la principauté de monaco où la princesse
à nouveau
devenu sa protectrice et son ami lui
offre l'asile et les berges
généreusement avec toute sa famille
ce jour de mars 1969
elle ne dit pas seulement à dieu à un
enracinement à ce paysage qu'elle aime
tant à son château sur la lune qu'elle
adorait est occupé depuis plus de 30 ans
elle dit adieu un rêve fou
celui d'installer au milan d'un collège
de la fraternité universelle
où elle souhaite que ce soit enseigner à
des enfants venus du monde entier la
tolérance la laïcité
le goût de l'égalité et de la fraternité
si ce collège
neuvy donc jamais le jour
l'adoption avec jo bouillon de 12
enfants
akio et et ruia venus du japon luis tu
colombie jarry de finlande jean claude
moïse noël de france
brian et marianne d'algérie koffi de
côte d'ivoire
tara du venezuela et stellina du maroc
oui
ses 12 enfants
cette famille permis à joséphine baker
de prouver aux yeux du monde que les
couleurs de peau les origines les
religions pouvait non seulement
cohabiter mais vivre en harmonie
vous êtes là ce soir
fidèle à ses rêves
cette tribu arc en ciel comme elle
l'appelait
est le plus beau des manifestes
humaniste
épiphanie de l'universalisme auquel elle
croyait temps
joséphine baker a quitté la vie en même
temps qu'elle quittait la scène
quelques heures après la seconde
représentation d'une revue consacrée à
sa vie
c'était à bobino
au coeur de ce quartier de la gaieté
dont le nom lui allait si bien
quelques jours plus tard le 15 avril
1975 des milliers de parisienne et de
parisiens
remonter la rue royale pour accompagner
son cercueil
déjà drapé de bleu blanc rouge faire
cette église de la madeleine où la
france en terre ces artistes
aujourd'hui
nous sommes encore là
même bleu blanc rouge pour la faire
entrer dans notre panthéon
alors ce soir joséphine baker entre ici
avec tous ces artistes qui
l'accompagnent tous ces artistes qui ont
aimé le jazz la danse le cubisme la
musique la liberté de ces années elles
entrent ici avec tous ceux qui comme
elle ont vu dans la france
une terre à vivre
un lieu où l'on cesseraient de se rêver
ailleurs
une promesse d'émancipation
elles entrent ici avec tous ceux qui ont
choisi la france
qui l'ont aimé et lemm
charnellement qui l'ont vu trébucher et
ont continué de l'est mais qu'ils ont vu
à terre et se sont battus pour la
relever
français par le sang versé les combats
menés
l'amour donné
elles entrent ici
pour nous rappeler à tous
pour nous rappeler à nous mêmes
kim et ont quelquefois
tendance nettement à vouloir l'oublier
l'insaisissable beauté de notre destin
collectif
nous qui sommes une nation de combat
fraternel
que l'on désire que l'on mérite
keane est elle même
que lorsqu'elle est grande et sans peur
joséphine baker
vous entrez dans notre panthéon où
s'engouffre avec vous
un vent de fantaisie et d'audace
oui pour la première fois ici
c'est une certaine idée de la liberté de
la fête qui entre aussi
vous entrez dans notre panthéon parce
que vous avez aimé la france
parce que vous lui avez montré un chemin
qui était le sien véritable
mais dont elle doutait pourtant
vous entrez dans notre panthéon
parce que nés américaine
au fond il n'ya pas plus française que
vous
est alors qu'à la fin de votre carrière
adaptant les paroles de votre plus grand
succès
vos claviers
mon pays c'est paris
chacun de nous ce soir
murmures ce refrain
sonnant comme un hymne à l'amour
ma france
c'est joséphine
vive la république vive la france
[Applaudissements]
allons enfants de la patrie
le jour de gloire est
arrivé
contre nous des laitiers ali et
sanglant
les audaces ou n'en ai entendu bonne
compagnie
référence cela
les causes et nos fils et nos compagnes
osa osa
cya
m
[Applaudissements]
taillon
le fond
k
sans bavure
m
chiant un mot sacré mal
qu'on lui souhaite
[Musique]
librairie
ansa
la peau basanée
des français
à
après grimal d'accent
[Musique]
on pourra construire
[Applaudissements]
le site web a
et
[Applaudissements]
taillon
jean
[Musique]
m
un as
environ
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci de nous retrouver en direct sur
figaro l'arrivée sur notre chaîne
youtube nous venons donc d'assister à
l'hommage solennel de la nation à
joséphine baker joséphine baker qui a
fait son entrée au panthéon aujourd'hui
lors d'une cérémonie présidée par le
président emmanuel macron qui vient de
délivrer un discours très attendu il est
en train en ce moment de remercier et de
saluer les personnes présentes dans
l'enceinte du panthéon on a pu voir le
prince albert de monaco l'un des enfants
aussi de joséphine baker
on voit sur ces images diffusées en ce
moment richard ferrand gérard larcher
jean michel blanquer donc des
personnalités politiques qui sont
également présentes et puis au cours de
cette cérémonie qui est en train de
s'achever on a pu apercevoir parmi les
personnalités issues du monde de la
culture line renaud
nous on a vu aussi les humoristes pascal
légitimus claudia tagbo qui étaient
présentes les chanteur abd al malik et
angélique kidjo et examens présent et
puis pour ceux qui suivaient cette
cérémonie avec nous en direct françois
cluzet est également a été aperçu à
l'image c'est que zabou breitman voilà
pour cette cérémonie très solennelle qui
s'achève je suis en plateau avec mon
invité christine clair que si mme claire
vous avez suivi cette cérémonie avec
nous cérémonie qui a duré plus d'une
heure maintenant
1h15 je crois qu est ce que vous avez
pensé qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir de
cette cérémonie en hommage à josé toutes
visé leurs têtes parce que nous ne
sommes pas présente sur la place du 21
ans avec l'atmosphère c'est vrai qu'au
début j'ai trouvé que tout ça a été un
peu dispersé qu'on ne retrouvais pas
vraiment le dire l'âme de joséphine
baker
ensuite le bruit dans le public on
craignait qu'il fût trop long là où pour
une fois il n'a pas fait trop long bon
on voit bien il a évoqué évidemment là
la liberté la réconciliation entre les
français c'est un message transmis
évidemment on attend toujours une
émotion j'avoue que je ne les pas du bon
je sais pas c'est un exercice très
difficile mais je pense que là le
message qu'il voulait envoyer à travers
traversée de cérémonie et par son
discours est évidemment un un message de
deux réunions de tous autour de nos
valeurs
cessons d'être opposés les uns aux
autres soyons la grande france qui ouvre
les bras bon le message il est passé par
le seul fait que joséphine baker entre
panthéon la cérémonie elle même on peut
regretter tel ou tel détail on peut
regretter un discours qui ne nous
soulève pas n'importe pas mais il est
vrai que je suis parmi les admiratrices
de ballereau et que c'est très démodé
on ne peut pas faire l'entrée se jean
moulin surtout quand le entre ici jean
moulin est précédé de tout un cortège de
toute une histoire dit à voix basse et
qui donne la chair de poule bon on lui
demandait pas de nous donner la chair de
poule c'était le geste dit de la faire
entrer et de nous rappeler qu'elle n'a
pas été qu'une chanteuse musicienne
avec une ceinture de bananes ou à quatre
pattes qu'elle a été une résistance et
c'est tout un pan de sa vie qu on avait
complètement de will i am in your il y
aurait ou oubliés en tout cas et ça
c'est vraiment c'est magnifique ça ça
redonne
la fierté d'être français c'est un peu
ça peut être contagieux on l'espère en
tout cas c'est le but de ce genre de
cérémonie alors que ce direct s'achève
en tout cas christine clerc vous qui
avouez que vous n'avez pas été très émue
par cette cérémonie est malgré tout
important je suis bon et c'est
techniquement
remarquable les internautes ont été émus
pour beaucoup d'entre eux jean-paul deux
fidèles internautes du figaro figaro là
il nous avoue qu'il avait de l'émotion
il a eu de l'émotion que c'était très
émouvant et pourtant dit il je n'ai
jamais envie de voir ce genre de
cérémonie habituellement
pour ceux qui ont été émus vous l'avez
été comme souvent par le chant des
partisans qui a été interprété par le
choeur de l'armée française et puis on a
pu voir aussi au début de cette
cérémonie la foule qui a bravé le froid
pour assister dehors au début de cette
cérémonie est hélas la remontée le long
de la rue soufflot du cercueil du
cénotaphe ce cercueil vide symbolique de
joséphine baker qui est donc entrée
aujourd'hui ce soir dans le panthéon
voilà on pouvait parler effectivement du
fait que la cérémonie était un peu figé
qu'elle ne reflétait pas à la
personnalité voilà riche des parents va
trouver parce
sa vivacité son enthousiasme sa chaîne
aurait pu voir des danseurs par exemple
alors c'est un choix apparemment café
l'elysée de ne pas donner à la cérémonie
un côté trop décalé
oui mais voilà donc on pourrait le
regretter effectivement mais enfin il
merci kessel et maurice druon est
toujours sur des partisans et ça c'est
magnifique et le méritez bien elle
méritait vraiment que ce fut chanté pour
elle
merci beaucoup christine clerc d'avoir
été avec nous pour commenter en direct
sur figaro live et notre chaîne youtube
cet événement cette entrée de joséphine
baker
grande résistante
militante de la lutte antiraciste et
puis évidemment grandes stars du music
hall on demander à des folles et bien
après
christine clerc je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste grand reporter prix
albert londres il faut le préciser et
écrivain votre dernier ouvrage domenica
à la diabolique et édité aux éditions de
l'observatoire on vous retrouve
peut-être bientôt sur figaro live si
l'occasion se représente ce sera avec
plaisir en tout cas merci merci aux
internautes de nous avoir suivis en
direct merci pour votre fidélité
à très vite sur figaro live
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]